at the time
I may have
may have overheated that
slightly
oh well
let me make sure yeah people
oh hang on
oh okay there we go
just realized I had the uh the audio
input coming from not the mic I intended
so there we go
that should do it
oh good
hope everyone is having a better week
than me
we'll go with that
ah good to see folks already here
Jack Cara cappuccino super Desi Pirates
Gozer Carolyn of course MC
uh
uh homebody J
transformative
doesn't quite roll off the tongue 255
A.T thank you everybody
do I like bubble tea
um occasionally if it's like I won't go
out of my way to get bubble tea but I
will if it's available somewhere that
I'm already at for something like
there's um
there's a foe there's a Vietnamese pho
restaurant in Montpelier that I like and
like they have bubble tea so I'll get
that there
uh how am how are you this week I found
out my favorite podcast for seven years
is a sex pass so I could be better I am
very sorry that
um
that was something that happened
whenever you know whenever somebody uh
you
have been
you know following or even creatively
look up to turns out to be awful
foreign
sucks it really sucks
um how am I
I'm still here
and you know when there is a very vocal
contingent of people uh expressing their
desire for you to not be here sometimes
simply
being present and visible is uh
that's a start
who that hat that is very hot
ah
I agree faux is great
uh what do I think is the best ERA of DC
Comics
I would say
from for my taste the 80s were pretty
good
um
it wouldn't really be until we got into
the 90s that some stuff that had started
in the 80s would start going overboard
and the 70s in the lead up to it was
pretty solid but I feel like it if
you're if I'm gonna give you a decade
80s was pretty solid for DC overall
ah
do I like the song Bring Me to Life by
Evanescence of course I do I'm assuming
you are pulling that reference from my
Twitter because on the Vera wild Twitter
I retweeted a thing that says I hint at
your age by saying the first concert you
went to I said Evanescence which is a
mild cheat because I'd been to some
concerts before that but they were
concerts that I was like
kind of dragged to one way or another
the first one that was like I want to go
to that that was Evanescence so that's
what I went with
um
if I could offer my two cents about the
James gundies Universe I'm cautiously
optimistic as am I but you know
um
favorite DC artist I'm oh I'm really bad
at remembering
artist names Kurt Swan was good
um
oh
freaking heck
there's like the there's a really great
one whose name I'm now I've now lost
there were a lot of good ones that whose
names I can't recall though a lot of the
artists that stuck with me were ones
that were drawing in image and Marvel in
the 90s because that's when I was paying
more attention
uh I I cannot promise I will be great at
keeping up with the chat tonight I will
do
um the best that I can I keep in mind
the one thing that will guarantee that I
get to your question is to do it in the
form of a Super Chat which will also get
you a little heart of appreciation from
me
here's some news release today that
would have been disappointing uh even if
the person question wasn't a total prick
now there's going to be a Faulty Towers
reboot ew why
like set aside issues with John Cleese
why why
what
I don't understand
like I I do not understand at all
why anyone would think somebody wants
that
that's the kind of thing that would have
if it gets decent ratings at all it's
for episode one
where everybody Tunes in to discover if
it's either exactly like the original in
which case they don't need it or it's
not enough like the original in which
case they don't want it and then
everybody drops off after that that
would be my expectation with a project
like that
yeah
every day hip above ground is a good day
it is it although I
had
uh
uh for uh a character and I have no like
setting or story to go with this but a
character that basically
wakes up every morning
and like upon waking up just realizes
they're still alive and goes
ah damn it and then just goes about
their day and I know that's kind of
morbid but I just kind of have it in my
mind this idea that someone's
perspective is like
I'll die when I meant to like they're
not gonna they're not gonna unalive
themselves or anything like that they're
just gonna go about uh and try and have
the best life that they can for however
long it lasts but they're kind of
annoyed that it keeps going I don't know
that might be a little bit too morbid
for today but
I thought I'd share that convinced the
people behind Tick Tock are
conservatives the people behind Tick
Tock are the Chinese government so you
know
take it as you will
one of my friends brought up an
interesting point about boycotting
Hogwarts mystery I'm assuming you mean
Hogwarts Legacy but okay uh wouldn't you
be hurting the developers more than
hurting rolling
ah
okay so I really
really
do not want the string to become about
Hogwarts Legacy I will address that
because it is a common refrain and
there's a couple of problems with that
the first is if you know anything about
uh development for video games
especially big budget video games what's
called AAA video games which this very
much is
you would know that a successful game is
no guarantee of continued employment
we can't know for sure whether or not
any of the devs would get any kind of
bonus based on sales of the game it's
possible sometimes that happens it is
not standard actually almost nothing
good is standard within the video game
industry because there are barely any
unions in it so the thing is
there is no reason to be sure that this
studio Avalanche Studios that is the
primary developer will be maintained at
the same Le at the same level with the
same amount of support and same number
of employees even as this game is a
master is a huge success
because whether or not they get closed
will have a lot more to do with what the
parent excuse me parent company Warner
Brothers interactive in this case
thinks is best for their bottom line
being successful is no guarantee you can
look at things like Activision that in
the same year that they announced
record-breaking Revenue they laid off
800 people you could look at just last
month and the entire Tech sector not
just video games but like video games
Google like across the board in the tech
sector massive layoffs this past month
it wasn't because any of the companies
were failing Microsoft laid off
thousands tens of thousands of people
and it wasn't because they lost money is
because they didn't grow by as much as
they had expected to and so to pad their
numbers they cut a bunch of people
because cutting expenses is a way to
fake growth my point is if your intent
is to help the developers the thing that
you should be doing is not blindly
buying a game especially considering you
don't know any of those developers not
to be a prick about it and if anyone
loses their job at that company I I feel
very bad for them I don't think they
should lose their job but again their
loss of their job if it happens will be
at the whims of Warner Brothers
if you want to help ensure that they can
keep work
doing whatever can be done to help push
for unionization within the video game
Space is a much better way to do that
not to mention the fact that entire line
of thinking comes from a perspective
that I find deeply troubling which is
that it assumes that there is an
obligation to consume it assumes that by
not buying a thing
that
you have caused harm you're not
obligated to spend money on anything
or you shouldn't be yet we frequently
hear it framed that not spending money
on a thing
would harm somebody
about that for a second
you are being talked to and about as if
you are obligated to support these devs
because by that logic you have closed
literally every Studio that's ever been
closed because you didn't buy every game
that was made why didn't you support
those Developers
it's an argument that doesn't track it
doesn't scan in any other possible
context besides the fact and this is
really
really important at least from my
perspective on what the purpose of
asking people to not buy that game was
the purpose was not a boycott I have
never used the word boycott in regards
to that game
for me speaking for myself the purpose
of bringing up the negative impact that
buying that game and how it supports JK
Rowling and the Damage she is doing was
to get people to not ignore it
some people would choose to ignore it
anyway deny that the connection is there
but if there was anybody who heard what
I said and actually thought and grappled
with that idea that was all I ever
wanted
I never had any realistic expectation
that we were going to starve the Harry
Potter franchise that this game was ever
going to be anything other than a
monstrous success it was always going to
be
so when we ask as trans people that you
not buy this game it's not because we
think we will ever get enough people to
not buy it that it will put a massive
dent in it that's not the point
the point is we're asking you in a very
straightforward situation where it is
very clear who benefits from this
purchase and what they are doing with
their influence we are asking you could
you not contribute to this person who's
harming us we are asking you for
solidarity we are asking you to make
what is a pretty straightforward and I
don't think especially difficult stand
to not buy a product
what it tells us is who is prepared to
stand with us at the most basic level in
who is going to abandon us the instant
it inconveniences them in any way shape
or form
so the devs so like the entire
theoretical but if nobody bought the
game the studio would shut down yeah
maybe but that was literally never going
to happen
and it was not something I ever called
for
so it's actually kind of an irrelevant
point it's an excuse brought up for
people who want to justify the thing
they already want to do they want to buy
that game and they want to find the
reason why it's okay for them to buy
that game that's assuming that
transphobia actually bothers them at all
there's demonstrably millions of people
who actually not only don't care think
it's a good thing but
if someone is grappling enough with it
that they feel the need to make an
argument like that
that to me says that they are grasping
at straws to find a reason why they
don't have to give up a thing in order
to extend
a helping hand or a good wish or a show
of support for a group of people that
may not include them and I say may
because there are plenty of trans people
who've said they're gonna buy it and
yeah they're still contributing to
transphobia too and I will note what I
have tried to note that has been
willfully ignored I say contributing to
transphobia not are transphobic
because there is a difference
and it's all very messy and I don't want
to go down that road any further than I
have
but there's that
hey
okay bunch of super chats came in so I
want to try and
catch up on these uh
so
super Desi
thank you very much for the Super Chat
you saw me with little heart for me also
I'll enable your faux habit ah thank you
they make amazing like it
how flavorful that broth is is Criminal
it's so good
thank you uh Ali Tomlinson music for the
Super Chat no comments were made with it
Supreme
Omega
thank you very much for that on your
criticisms of Tong King a lot of it
wasn't his fault it can be laid on the
Dio who wanted to horrifically kill Dick
and Wally multiple times isn't Deo gone
hasn't he been gone for a while did I I
could have sworn he was gone
hold on
give me a second here Dan de Dio
[Music]
yeah he was out by 2020.
and not all of Tom King's stuff was
within that time frame I don't think
maybe it all was time is uh is a
disaster and trying to sort it out is uh
well outside my own uh personal purview
sorry give me one second
so
um
the thing is
the thing that I
personally
uh got ticked off at Tom King for uh is
his fault
and that was the Batman Catwoman's
getting married thing
um and it's not the fact that he almost
got them married it's not even the fact
that he that he chickened out and went
no I'm not gonna do it it was the fact
that he sat down in interviews and said
yes we're really gonna get these
characters Married
because I think
that there are stories that are not
being told about characters in committed
relationships and he was right and he
was lying
because he was never actually going to
put them together
I appreciate being lied to
by creators I just don't
and nobody made him do that
now the main thing that I've heard about
Tom King that appears to be in his
defense is that when he is working on
very small self-contained stuff he can
be quite good it's when he deals with
bigger stuff that it all falls apart he
was in crisis
oh yeah
uh Dharma
very much
free upping the uh the membership
14 months uh six months 14 months
subscription six months HRT zero regrets
ah
thank you very much
uh 255 A.D thank you every industry
created after the 70s has no unions
some truth to that I don't know how
across the board it is but yeah yeah
newer Industries
uh deeply lack unionization
uh John vinyls thank you for the Super
Chat leaving aside how horrible her
bigotry truly is doesn't you know who
recognize how
she's harming her brand like people
still love those books uh even after
um all this stuff if she could shut her
mouth they'd still be Beloved the thing
is though she looks at her residual
checks and she doesn't think she's lost
anybody
the read that I have on her is she
believes the people who who she is lost
um
are
just
trans people
and
the stuff's all still successful
the only thing that's really
Tanked
has been the Fantastic Beasts movies and
even those it wasn't by the third one
that they were truly done
um
and you know it was diminishing returns
but
she still sells books and this game yeah
no she doesn't
no she doesn't recognize how she's
harming her brand because in her mind
every single sale of a Harry Potter
product
is proof If not that people agree with
her that at the very least they are not
turned off by what she's saying
although she seems to be operating from
the position of if they buy my product
they agree with me
which is why I pointed out before even
if you think
that you can divorce her from that
property and you think that
um
that you know not believing what she is
saying makes it okay she thinks you're
on her side
she treats your money and your purchase
like you're on her side
[Music]
Jay Gray thank you very much not for a
penny not for a pound
ah
everyone already being used for
something else do you think Q would be a
good shorthand for the LGBT plus
Community as a whole I I personally do
consider queer to be a blanket
um identity it's a good all-purpose it
can refer to everything or to someone
who maybe has multiple identities like
speaking as someone who's
through both gender identity and
sexuality is taking up multiple letters
on that thing queer is a nice catch-all
um
is that a top or a dress it's a top
it's a top it's not a dress and I'm not
wearing pants
or am I
did I just try to like be all
um sort of implying stuff with the
notion that I actually was where I I
screwed that up I got that backwards
oh well
not queer simply Q the letter oh
see I'm a bad person to ask because I
don't like just using single letters I
don't like acronyms I don't like
abbreviations partially because my brain
is really bad at keeping track of them
so I wouldn't like it
uh
I like your necklace thank you this was
actually given to me by one of my
co-workers at the uh at the old job
before I was doing this full-time
I have someone pressuring me to see the
last Fantastic Beasts movie despite
knowing how I feel about JKR why like by
most accounts it wasn't even a good
movie and like if if they just think you
should know what happened
read the Wikipedia entry
[Music]
I don't get that
I don't believe you're aware's pants on
stream I said what I said
yeah you did
check out Quantum Leap 2022 if you want
great representation I've heard about
that Whitney I don't know
I don't know if or when
I will get to it
um because I am
seriously buried and behind a lot of
stuff so but I did hear that what's in
my mug it is hot apple cider is what's
in there which is why I'm sick sipping
it it was almost said sickness sipping
it as delicately as I am in this
particular particular scenario
I'm excited for Superman Legacy and I'm
willing to give the flash a shot on the
other hand I'm not sure about the
characters moving into and out of
Animation you know I mean it depends on
what the characters are
I suppose I don't know if I want to see
The Flash no I'll backtrack that I don't
want to see The Flash
and it's just a question of whether to
what extent I feel like I can get away
with not watching it because
ah
just I'm so sick of talking about these
people I'm so sick of Ezra Miller I'm so
sick of JK really I'm so sick of Joshua
and I'm sick of John Barrowman I'm sick
to
death of
all of them
ah
255 A.D
thank you very much for the Super Chat
would you consider CIS hat cross
dressing as part of the queer community
um okay
boy that's uh
that's an old school loaded topic
speaking as someone
who used to identify at well I never
identified as heterosexual who did
identify as cisgender cross-dresser for
a long time a long time
my feelings on that are
they kind of default to
um whether or not the person wants to be
identified with that Community it's kind
of the first thing
because I think
there is I wouldn't hesitate guess as to
whether or not it's a majority
but I feel comfortable in saying there
is a significant percentage of
CIS hetero cross-dressers
who for how they conceive of themselves
would not want to be
um sort of put in and considered with
the rest of the queer community
and I wouldn't I wouldn't feel okay sort
of forcing that label on them if it's
not one they're comfortable with
so I suppose if we narrow the field and
we say what would my thoughts be
on a CIS het cross-dresser who did
feel that they belonged within the queer
community
I guess my next question
would be
to what degree like are they
um
attempting to make use of queer support
networks are do they simply wish to
march with queer people at Pride like
the former is a little like ah the
latter is like yes please do
um it gets weird it feels
honestly it feels very Case by case to
me I don't feel comfortable making a
blanket statement on that
um
for I think a combination of reasons
being one
I don't know how this hypothetical
person would identify for themselves in
the first place I mean if they're if
they believe they if they if they feel
and they are firm in their conviction
that they are in fact CIS hat
um but who just cross-dressed I would
imagine they probably would not have
much desire to be in queer spaces and if
they did I would it would help for me to
like sit down and have a conversation
with them and be like okay why
because if you are cisgender and you are
heterosexual
I'm not gonna say you can't be here but
I'm going to be curious as to why you
desire to be and I don't mean that in a
gatekeeping way it's just that if you
think you are both of those things
why would you be in queer spaces
and that's a genuine confusion that's
not a leading question that's not me
implying it must be because of this
nefarious thing like I don't know I
genuinely don't know like I found myself
in queer spaces back when I thought I
was cisgender if only for virtue of the
fact that I wasn't straight
so
you know I always had that to fall back
on if my presence was questioned back in
the day
but I don't know I feel I feel like if
that person exists I kind of want to sit
down and have a call and have a
conversation with them and and not be
operating on a ton of assumptions which
is kind of what I'm stuck with and
granted that's the nature of a
hypothetical but
you get what I mean you get it
you get it
this guy this person
I use guy as a very non-gendered term
hey guys these guys this guy over here
I used Dude non-gendered too I'm trying
to cut back back on both of those
they're pretty ingrained
okay let's see we got some more Super
chats in here
John Wiles what do we got
uh you uh you can't look at you know who
without thinking about all the authors
who are raised and bigoted societies and
still work to overcome those prejudices
and learn to be better people
I mean
I'm not
going to even attempt to parse
what to what degree the views of someone
like
uh she who will not be named I've
already named her this stream anyways
but
um
to what degree
the various aspects that have
contributed to her views is you know
responsible to what degree is it
societal to what degree is it a result
of trauma which is something she's
talked about to what degree is it um
indoctrination
by uh you know aspects and uh people in
the gender critical subculture that just
drew her in and radicalized her to what
degree is it any of this I don't know
I don't know I can't know and ultimately
at the end of the day it doesn't really
matter
to me
that's the kind of stuff that like if
someone wants to try and create a
psychological profile on her which don't
do that
I've said before don't do that like I
don't understand why
those aspects would matter
but like as you say there are plenty of
people in plenty of inherently bigoted
societies that are who find ways to
overcome that
but that kind of also makes the point
that
yes that does happen but someone who
does that has beaten the odds
because the society that has a lot of
inbuilt prejudices
um in its makeup in its fundamental
makeup
those are going to be harder to a be
aware of and be shaked off and most
people won't and even those who do are
probably still going to be dealing with
residual BS in their heads for the rest
of their lives I know I am
so
while it is always admirable
that certain people are able to break
out of the mentalities instilled in them
by Society by teachers by parents by
Church by whatever it may be
while that will always be admirable
we need to remember that just because
some people could do it doesn't mean
everybody can
I don't want to make it completely
analogous to trying to break out of
poverty because it's not quite but it is
that same kind of thing it's very easy
to admire
someone who started at the bottom and
got to a high point but you need to
remember that they are the exception and
there are built-in problems that are
keeping most people from being able to
do that
and that is not to remove to bring it
back to prejudices that is not to remove
responsibility for those views and the
impact of speaking those views out loud
from these people they are absolutely
responsible for the things they say and
the impact and the results of those
things yes absolutely
but
at the same time the reason I say it's
important to keep in mind that most
people don't beat those odds is because
we need to keep our eye on societal
change and not only on the individuals
as much harm as some of them are doing
ah
all right what do we got next sorry I'm
I'm not getting to the chat as much we
have more Super chats than we've had in
a while which
honestly I really do appreciate I I
won't lie I was nervous coming into this
chat today just with how the last
week and a half two weeks have been Carl
Watson any ideas tips places to go to
get a magic system up and running I have
zero ideas I feel like I don't have the
brains for it okay so I'm assuming we
are talking within fiction within
fantasy
um at this point
sorry give me one second
all right sorry about that uh
so okay uh Magic system
um
I think the I for me at least and I've
created a couple of magic systems but
largely by dictation of what I wanted to
do with a story
story
I can talk
um
so
the the thing with magic systems I find
is the first thing well let me back up
for me and my way of approaching stories
it always helps to know what is the
story you wish to tell overall and then
what magic system
will enable you to best tell that story
and the best place to start is what is
it you want magic to be able to do what
do you not want it to be able to do
so what I mean by that when I was
creating the magic systems for dreams of
Fire
it was especially for the Elementals it
was incredibly limited that was by
necessity because I wanted the impact
and the effects of it to be very narrow
because I wanted the people who had it
to have very little control over it and
if it was wild magic that could do
anything like it could transform a tree
into a horse or it could bring rain
clouds or it could turn day into night
or whatever
the fact that they didn't have control
over it just basically meant I might as
well roll a hundred-sided die at the
start of every chapter for whatever
random things gonna happen I'm not
saying you can't do that but I didn't
want to so I narrowed that magic system
very deliberately because I knew at its
core I did not want people to have good
control over it so figure out what do
you want magic to do and to not do
start there and see if you can from
there work out a system that gives you
the restrictions you want while giving
you the freedom you need
and I say that as someone who can't just
sit down and World build
I can't I can't just sit down and come
up with a with a map and a history and a
religion and a magic system for the heck
of it some people can I can't I need to
know what story is this in service of so
for me and if you're if you write
anything like how I write then that is
what I would start with figure out the
narrative overall like and that doesn't
mean you have to outline the things
start to finish but figure out what the
basics and the core of what you want
this story to be and then figure out
okay within that understanding what do I
want magic to do what do I want magic to
not do
and then work on something to build
those constraints oh hey Meg let's go
let's see you
ah okay uh back to the super chats
because I've got more of those
on a lighter note and this is from John
vinyls thank you so much again
um I think about how funny it is the
thing that Dana Terence created the
character of Lena saber and DuckTales
2017. oh that was hers
uh I'm gonna miss the owl house when
that's done
I'm gonna miss that show a lot
Supreme Omega
on guns DC plan at least he's mostly
drawing from pre-new 52 material yes
thank goodness
because my issue with recent DC films
and TVs that is mostly adapt to the new
52 stuff the instant the animated DC
stuff started a continuing continuity
based off the new 52 was the instant
they started being consistently bad
they used to be reliably great and there
were a couple of good ones that came
about even after that happened but most
of them were really bad it's because the
new 52 was cool
it was
so bad
New 52 was awful
terrible
anyways
[Music]
255 A.D have you started state of the
art yet I think uh I think you'll not
like it or at least it'll frustrate you
that's my feeling anyway I have not
started it yet I have
no
I I am I've got a lot of stuff breathing
down my neck including uh my tax bill
for last year I will get to it as soon
as I can I have not started it yet
a j
thank you you're an absolute icon I love
your content oh
thank you
I appreciate that
ah
and 255 A.D again thank you for that
weird that I commissioned a story I have
issues with I mean
not really if you
like there are plenty of things I have
issues with but are still interesting to
talk about honestly
it's at least for me
it's very difficult to find a way to
talk about something that
I just think is great across the board
like I can get excited about it but
I find it a lot more interesting to to
talk about something that like has a lot
of potential but doesn't quite get there
like I mean is why I was able to spend
like 40 minutes talking about Zack
Snyder's Watchman movie because I'm
fascinated by the fact that it doesn't
work
uh Jack Frederick member for 10 months
thank you very much hi there insert
profound question statement here my Jack
that was indeed most profound
Diana Bell New 52 Batwoman was really
good until they effed everything up and
the good people quit I mean that's what
happened to most of the stuff that was
at any point uh any good with the new 52
but most of it was garbage
like immediately
the new 52 Wonder Woman
is part of why I will probably have a
lifelong grudge against Brian azarello
because
oh my God
oh my God it was
oh it was so bad
ah
[Music]
John vinyl's back again
would love to hear your favorite season
of DuckTales 2017 also am I the only
person who finds Andreas from amphibia
to be a really great Disney antagonist
he is a good antagonist I mean part of
that's Keith David because
Keith David's voice
oh
oh my goodness
oh that man's voice
I'm okay I'm okay
um but yeah Andreas is a well-developed
antagonist and he's intimidating he
works really well as for my
um
favorite season of DuckTales I don't
know because I have
still haven't actually finished it I've
seen the first
three
seasons
I think
um and unfortunately they all bleed
together on me
I think I like this I can see some of
the ones I've seen the best I don't
uh I wouldn't swear by that though
it's been a little while it's one of
those things that I like I I'll be like
oh I should get back to that and I'll
watch two episodes and then I won't
check it again for a month
uh
what are my thoughts on hate watching I
never made sense to me like if you hate
something why do you give it the time of
day
all right
I I
get hate watching
for something that isn't a commitment
so like I get hate watching a movie
I get check out a movie that you think
is going to suck
to sink 90 minutes to two and a half
hours of your life into it
and just to confirm because sometimes
there have been things that I've wanted
to sound off on but I'm like uh
I'm gonna be I might be half informed if
I don't actually watch the thing and
then I watch the thing and I'm like boy
I hated that and now I can properly
articulate why I get hate watching
single episodes a TV show what I don't
get is hate watching a series over a
long term I don't get that I don't get
you know the desire to come back over
and over and over again to refill on
hate
I do get the invigoration of like
I hated that there can be an
invigoration to that but going back to
that like for week after week for a show
no I don't get it I mean that said at
least most of the most prolific hate
Watchers tend to be
people who also commentate on it be it
as a hobby or a professionally and so
there can be a sense of obligation like
I'm not gonna say I ever got to the
point of hate watching Doctor Who but
the last few series of Doctor Who I have
disliked a lot more than I've liked and
I didn't love that fact but I kept
watching it because it's my job
uh the plot is going to be Basel opening
a new hotel and the daughters he's only
just discovered he has played by kelis's
own daughter Camilla
oh so Chris is coming back for this
so this isn't this isn't this isn't a
reboot this is a this is a continuation
after a long Gap this is like the Night
Court thing
okay that
that makes slightly more sense
slightly
um at least more so than a flat out
reboot reboot
what's my opinion on Blobby the Blobfish
I have no idea what that is
anytime I hear Keith David I immediately
think of Goliath from gargoyles I mean
that's where I discovered him so I get
that
am I going to catch the address
I don't know what that is either
Black cover you are you're just coming
at me with stuff that I'm like I don't
know what that is
ah
uh what are my top 10 pieces favorite
top 10 pieces of media and why oh good
grief that is that that would eat up the
rest of the stream I'm not
uh how long should I expect to wait for
you to get to State of the art I would
like two years for recession and then I
got surface detail in a few months it
will not be two years
I would like to have state of the art
done before we get into the summer I do
not have a certain time commitment I am
behind on a lot including other people's
commissions part of the reason that I
was able to do except uh service detail
in a much shorter time frame was because
I could get the audiobook and I couldn't
with accession
so you got to keep this stuff in mind
I'm doing my best
is there a movie or TV show where the
more you think about it the more you
hate it oh probably but I kind of don't
want to be in that space right now oh
the State of the Union oh God no I'm not
watching that I never watch that no
matter who it is
I don't give a [__] what the what these
people have to say because they get up
and mutter their way through something
to either appease or tick off a bunch of
people who should have been out of that
job decades ago no
no
well I I ha I never have and never will
watch a state of the union
you'd have to pay me
John vinyls actually DuckTales 2017 they
only had three seasons okay then I guess
I'm at the start of the third season
maybe I don't know
I don't know as I said
it's it's very sporadic my getting to it
255 A.D that's fine thank you for
understanding
uh okay
so I do have to as Carolyn pointed out I
do have to address the
um
Discord I will be back in just a couple
of minutes
and a reminder that the Council of Geeks
Discord is a patreon exclusive perk at
the two dollar and up tier gives you
access to the Discord so consider
supporting me on patreon if you don't
already and there are links in the
description
as much as YouTube does help and the
super chats again for everybody who's
done that
um the regular payouts from patreon are
the biggest thing that keeps my head
above water not the only thing and I
need all the other stuff too but it's
the biggest part
all right you have unlimited Capital to
start your own retro video game
developer Publishing House what kind of
games
uh would you want to have made and why
see the first thing that comes to my
head
is something that just oh God
I've been playing a game that's in Early
Access right now called Scarlet Maiden
if you are under 18 do not
look it up
um but
uh sorry give me one second
so I've been enjoying that a lot and it
is a spicy game and what I like about it
is a very well designed game where the
spiciness is
um constant but not actually
um
interrupting the game play uh
drastically so that that has been
I've been enjoying that a lot but like
I don't know because like I'm not a game
designer
ultimately
um so I know what kind of stuff I
gravitate to playing but like there's
lots of other people
you know already making
that stuff I know because I'm playing it
sorry there's something on my screen
what the hell is that
the hell
weird
um
so
I don't know I think I would be a very
like it would be a very bad person to
dictate the creative Direction I think
foreign
so unfortunately that's one of those
questions that it's a really interesting
question that I'm a very boring uh
person to answer it
uh hope you're doing all right
um
let let's keep it light with a question
favorite planet or other celestial
object
honestly I'll go classic I like the Moon
I think the Moon is awesome
and the spirit of the above waffles
pancakes or crumpets
none of the above
sorry waffles and pancakes are they're
too sweet for my taste crumpets I think
I've had a crumpet once and I don't
remember what it was like
so
I would rather get a bagel or or an
English muffin
favorite comfort read Restaurant at the
End of the Universe
uh or possibly uh life the universe and
everything
ideally
ideally done uh with the audiobook read
by Douglas Adams because he did it best
who does the better American accent
Andrew Garfield Charlie Cox or Robert
Pattinson hi
I'd say Garfield's Garfield's got it
down pretty well
so that will actually take care of the
Discord questions
um normally uh folks get three I did
request because I'm I'm a little drained
and I wasn't sure
uh this direct the direction this
particular shame was gonna go
um
so I did I did ask people to only submit
one this time so that's why it was
shorter
ah 255 A.D
thank you for the super chat with no
comment and thank you again for the
other one sorry for misreading it's okay
don't
don't worry about it
Charlie Cox does a great job yeah
Charlie Cox does pretty well
um Robert Patterson I don't think does
especially great but he's it's fine I
don't find him distracting
spicy game in a spicy website yeah
a little
a little bit
uh wait do you do adult media reviews on
your other spicy platform
um it's funny you should ask that
at present
no but
because of um
because I'm really enjoying that game
and I've finished the Early Access
version uh well almost
um but
I to fully explain everything that I
love about it would require footage and
I couldn't show footage on any of the
channels I've got on YouTube uh
so what I'm considering doing
is doing a review of it
uh that would
it would be just me talking about it and
put that on the Vera wild Channel
but have a version of that same review
featuring actual gameplay footage have
that go up on the spicy
site you know the one the one that's
that's it's meant mostly for fans mostly
maybe it's only I don't know I can never
remember that one I am thinking about
doing that we'll see
at the risk of ruining your mood have
you any words for Andrew Tate no he I
have no desire to expend any words to or
towards or at or in regards to he is
beneath consideration
sounds like a patreon exclusive
[Laughter]
[Music]
our Savory pancakes a thing in the U.S
not really you know what we do have
um in Vermont that I really like we have
a we have a chain restaurant called the
skinny pancake which is a crepe uh
restaurant sorry clip a restaurant and
they do savory the Savory Savory uh
clips and they're really good like the
sweet ones are nice too but the Savory
ones are
[Music]
so good
so good which X-Men would I be and why
um
see I go back and forth between
Kitty pride and Nightcrawler cause
they're freaking awesome now that's
going with like people who are
consistently members of the X-Men an
occasional Ally of the X-Men which would
be the ultimate go-to if we're just
encompassing all mutants is Mystique
because
find me a gender fluid person who
doesn't want shape-shifting abilities
uh and I'll be very surprised
uh what's my favorite Pokemon as well as
Pokemon Generation or game I have only
ever played
a couple of hours of Pokemon yellow and
Pokemon go so I don't feel comfortable
having an opinion on that
not a question just wanted to say I'm
very happy about the fact that you're
not going anywhere emotional nod
commences thank you Ben I appreciate
that
uh have you heard of uh hokuto no Ken
this was a North star I have heard of it
I have heard of it I have not seen it or
read it but I have heard of it
am I going to watch Moon girl and devil
dinosaur I'm not expecting to I'm glad
that it exists and it looks Nifty but it
also doesn't have a super amount of
appeal
to me
just doesn't so
isn't every trans person slowly becoming
Magneto now
uh philosophically possibly give it some
time and enough
uh
enough things going south Maybe
I would be magic and Mystique oh
interesting pics
uh Magic but not the movie version oh no
we no we Carolyn we don't count her at
all so
Mystique is Mother and Daddy
uh
it would be terrible and it would be an
awful idea of a part of me when Marvel
inevitably gets around to starting to do
the X-Men
and we get some version of Mystique
there's part of me that would just love
seeing where she looks
you know more or less like herself Call
Me Mommy shifts to look masculine or
call me Daddy
like they shouldn't actually do that I I
should not they should not actually do
that that's just the thing in my head
that I'm like I kind of want to see it I
kind of wanted to exist even though it
shouldn't
not an official media at any rate oh I
could commission somebody to make that
for me
oh to have disposable income
Pokemon Yellow did you get I don't
remember this was 20 years this was over
20 years ago I do not remember
so I looked Scarlett made enough that is
a lot
um yeah it is but it's a shockingly
competent game
I I actually legitimately enjoy it
as a game
because at this point most of the
novelty
excuse me most of the novelty
um
of his presentation has has worn off a
little bit and I'm still playing it
because it's actually just fun as a game
ah oh this might cheer you up uh as of
the book I'm reading it turns out that
both your favorite doctors number 12 and
number seven punch racists
yes
it is always
Justified to punch a Nazi
so
I remember I think it was on tick tock
seeing a comparison between
a liberal and a leftist
a liberal says
oh you shouldn't uh you shouldn't punch
a Nazi because then are you really any
better than they are
and a leftist says hey you know what if
you break a Nazi's arm that's one fewer
arms they have to do Nazi stuff with
so
is MCU killmonger or Magneto oh
um
hmm
he's got Magneto aspects and the thing
is I don't know enough about killmonger
from the comics to know how much they
retooled him
but uh Meg thank you for the Super Chat
very fittingly
666. love it do you have a favorite
version of the character and or story of
Dracula
I'm honestly
I know it's dated but I'm kind of a
sucker for Bella Lugosi
he had a presence that puts a stamp on
the character in a way that basically
every other interpretation of the
character since has either had to very
severely lean into what he did or run as
far away from possible from what he did
very few actors have been able to Simply
exist in the part the way Bella Lugosi
did with just a presence and like
it is
cheesy flatly it is cheesy that they
have the camera just going tight on his
eyes and he's like just staring at
someone it's supposed to convey that
he's hypnotizing someone but the man had
a presence and an energy in his eyes for
my doctor who fans out there similar to
how Roger Delgado was able to sell as
the master just looking at somebody
and overtaking their will Bella Lugosi
could do that
and especially in compared to most of
the interpretations of Dracula that have
come since he's very low key he is
menacing he is threatening
but he's not a show-off
he doesn't have to be
I think part of the reason I like his
Dracula is part of the same reason I
prefer the version of Smaug the dragon
from the
um
Rank and bass animated version of The
Hobbit to Benedict Cumberbatch version
from the movies
because the Cumberbatch version was very
all of his lines very
snarly
where are you Thief I smell you you know
he's he he was trying to be scary
what I love about the smog in the
animated Rank and bass version is he
doesn't have to try
he just is he's almost disaffected when
Bilbo shows up well Thief I smell you
feel your air
I can hear your breath he's not bothered
he doesn't need to be
he doesn't need to act scary he just is
scary and I feel similarly to
lugosi's Dracula he doesn't have to act
men as singer and Timmy he doesn't have
to do this extra work he just is
and I love that
hype yes Carolyn I will get to that in
just a moment I've got one more Super
Chat to hit
Supremo Mega I love rolling the r on
that one so much fun comic question if
it weren't for the comics code do you
feel Comics would be popular besides
just superheroes with different genres
and have a wider readership
um
possibly
so
here's the thing the thing to remember
is the comics code
didn't kill off every non-superhero
genre it killed off horror and it killed
it hard that probably would have stayed
popular but most of the other genres
that fell off fell off on their own not
because of the comics code but just
because there wasn't that much sustained
interest in them
Western Comics
um
you know a lot of uh Space Adventure
Comics romance Comics they fell off not
because they were dictated out of the
out of existence by the comics code the
way the horror comics specifically were
but just because they
they didn't they couldn't compete people
weren't as interested in them and that's
that was just the nature of the world at
that time so I like horror comics would
definitely would have stuck around at
the time but they might have still died
off the same as some of these others did
it's impossible to say
oh and somebody sneaking in another
Super Chat John vinyls thank you thank
you very much uh speaking of Lugosi I
love to imagine alternate worlds where
the owl house and amphibia were based on
Old books with several previous
adaptations oh that is interesting
huh Nifty
I especially love the animated smogs
Revenge you ah oh God it's so good
that's the thing he doesn't raise his
voice until he feels a little bit
insulted or when he realized he's been
stolen from
that's when he's mad not just because
somebody's in his lair he's like he
couldn't give a crap
cumberbatch's smog was Benedict
imitating the way his father voiced smog
when reading the story to Baby Benedict
and I can appreciate that and no shade
to
to cumberbatch's Dad but you know
it's not as good I'm sorry it's not
so can we assume Dwight Friar is your
favorite Renfield then or is Tom Waits
just too strong it's Tom Waits Rowan Tom
wait Tom Waits is Renfield
mwah
oh he's real good
I like Tom Waits pretty much anytime
he's on screen he's a very commanding
presence for a guy who only acts on
occasion but
okay let's wrap it up
for the day
um so stuff coming up tomorrow I will be
um
streaming on Twitch I'll be playing some
Hades just to unwind
um because the last couple of 2D
platformy games have ticked me off and
I'm gonna take a break from the genre
actually and we're gonna do a bit of
Hades it is gonna be a slightly late
start it'll be at 11 instead of 10 30
because I have some stuff going on in
the morning that I need to deal with
uh tomorrow we'll also see the premiere
of the latest take two Doctor Who review
that will be the one on ascension of the
Cybermen it would have been out last
week but it got bumped
um so that will be going on and then uh
well there is already a review up right
now uh for the latest episode of The Owl
House fight The Future that is up in the
break room of Geeks
and that is what is on the immediate
Horizon Friday will be on Twitch again
uh if I haven't found something else to
play maybe more Hades I don't know I'll
figure that out but that is everything
coming up
um if you did used to follow me on Tick
Tock and are aware that that uh
my last account my second account
um got uh falsely reported for a bunch
of stuff and is now gone you can now
find uh Vera wild one altogether the
numeral one at the end that is the new
account if you want to follow me on
Twitch not twitch on Tick Tock uh
probably will be a bit of a drip feed on
um
on that because I don't feel like diving
back into it right off
please slow down your speech sorry Meg I
uh
I speed through and I ramble when I feel
like I'm running out of time so
apologies uh oh gamer Jamie you snuck in
with uh Super Chat at the very end
speaking battle house do you have a
favorite episode I'm still really
partial to Grom
I just damn
but anyways thank you everybody for your
time your generosity your kindness
and your ears
that's a weird way to put it thank you
for your ears
uh whatever
I'm done I'm done uh anyway thank you
all for joining me and please remember
that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
Council is adjourned
mckevity